Speaker 1: Dozens of you sent me this clip that
we're going to look at, Congresswoman Debbie
Lesko, who's a Republican. I probably didn't
have to tell you that. You could figure it out
from what she said. She's from Arizona. She said
on the floor of the House of Representatives that
she would do anything for her own grandchildren,
including shooting them. What? What does that even
mean? Now, did she just misspeak? Well, if she
did, she hasn't clarified it. She's responded
to criticism of this bizarre statement by saying
people are attacking her and all these different.
If she misspoke, she could just say she's
misspoke. But let's take a look at what she said.
Speaker 3: Arizona is recognized for 2 minutes.
Speaker 4: Thank you, Representative Jordan.
I rise in opposition to H.R. 23, 77. Oh, I
have five grandchildren. I would do anything,
anything to protect my five grandchildren,
including as a last resort. Shooting them if I
had to. To protect the lives of my grandchildren.
Speaker 1: What have we really gone so woke that a
God fearing, flag waving Republican can't shoot
her own grandchildren to save them? What on
earth is this mean? Like if they're about to shoot
themselves dead? She would shoot them in the hand.
So they drop the gun and don't kill themselves.
Like what? What does it even mean? What possible
scenario? Would this even be an option? And the
scenario I'm landing on is she seems very unstable
and should probably have guns taken away. It
sounds like she's very, very dangerous. Now,
what was her response to this? Lesko responded
by attacking so-called gun control zealots
for suggesting she would shoot her own
grandchildren. But that's exactly what she said.
Instead of attacking the people saying, What the
hell is she talking about as zealots, she could
just say, Oh, I misspoke. I did say I would shoot
my grandchildren, but that's not what I meant.
Oh, all right. Well, that's simple.
Newsweek reports that Debbie Lesko
suggested her critics are misrepresenting
her comments. Well, I just played it for you.
We can listen to it one more time. It was very.
Speaker 3: Nice for 2 minutes.
Speaker 4: Thank you, Representative
Jordan. I rise in opposition to H.R. 2377.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 4: I have five grandchildren.
Speaker 1: I have five grandchildren.
Speaker 4: I would do anything,
anything to protect my five grandchildren.
Speaker 1: She would do anything to protect
her grandchildren.
Speaker 4: Including
as a last resort, shooting them.
Speaker 1: Including as a last resort.
Shooting them now. Is there some other noun in the
sentence that she might be referring to when she
says them? No. The only noun she has talked about
is her grandchildren. So why can't she just say,
I misspoke? I sit in my in my zealous defense of
my own grandchildren. I misspoke. What I meant was
I would even go so far as to shoot an intruder
in order to save my grandchildren. Why can't you
just say that is. This is the Trumpian influence.
She says something bonkers. It might be as simple
as she misspoke. And her response is to attack
so-called gun control zealots for going after her.
I guess this is part of the whole Trumpian
thing where you can't apologize anymore or
you can't just say, I just said the wrong
thing. I misspoke. You can't do it anymore.
So she just has to attack people. Bizarre stuff.
I hope somebody has checked it just to be safe.
I hope someone has checked
on her five grandchildren.